viele unternehmen könnten das rettende
ufer nicht erreichen diese angst treibt
die deutsche wirtschaft um milliarden an
hilfen sind seit beginn der korona krise
bericht waren da aber ob die viel
gepriesene bazooka diese milliarden-
test sicher ins ziel bringt mit der
nötigen feuerkraft darüber ist massiver
streit ausgebrochen
höchste zeit also einem gipfel
einzuberufen
der bundeswirtschaftsminister heute
getan krisen treffen wie kommt die
wirtschaft wieder in gang jetzt in der
phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde herzlich willkommen bei
uns meine gäste zunächst hier im studio
bei uns ist ingrid hartges die
hauptgeschäftsführerin des deutschen
hotel und gaststättenverbandes dehoga
ebenso wie dorothea siems chefökonomen
der tageszeitung die welt und
zugeschaltet ist uns schon ihn budelmann
unternehmerinnen von budelmann
electronics eine firma die sich mit der
berühmten industrie 4.0 beschäftigt also
mit maschinen intelligenz all das was
ihnen was uns in den nächsten jahren und
jahrzehnten blühen wird und schließlich
stefan genth ist der
hauptgeschäftsführer des hde der
spitzenorganisation des deutschen
einzelhandels mit ungefähr 100.000
mitgliedern liebe zuschauer bevor wir
hier in die diskussion einsteigen der
anlass ich habe sie am anfang gesagt
dieser sendung ist ja der sogenannte
wirtschaftsgipfel mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister und 40
verbandsvertretern und nach dem
wirtschaftsgipfel hat sich peter
altmaier vor der presse geäußert
wir haben uns darauf verständigt in den
nächsten tagen sehr zeitnah die
einzelnen vorschläge zu konkretisieren
und dann den versuch zu machen sie auf
einem in einer verständlichen form
zusammen zu führen ich glaube dass wir
eine gute chance haben dass dies gelingt
und dass wir damit auch die anstehenden
beratungen mit gestalten und prägen
können vor hat es also das ging ja
irgendwie ziemlich zuversichtlich wenn
man sich die vorberichterstattung
angesehen hat da wurde ja massiv
kritisiert der gipfel käme zu spät und
möglicherweise wäre das nur ein
schaufenster dreßen jetzt sagt ja der
bundeswirtschaftsminister
wir haben uns verständigt wir
kommunizieren wir sehen gute chancen
dass es gelingt dass wir gestalten
können das sind ja alles positiv
besetzte begriffe können sie das
bestätigen dass das ein ähnliches
treffen war also ich denke meine sind
gute verabredungen getroffen worden also
einmal was jetzt die schnelligkeit der
auszahlung der
anbelangt auf verbesserung der hilfen
hat er in aussicht gestellt und auch
teilweise konkret zugesagt und darüber
hinaus ist einfach wichtig dass die
stimme der wirtschaft gehört wird in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundeskanzlerin
die länder sind zwar zuständig dafür
aber wir wissen ja um das hick hack und
mir ist in der letzten zeit die balance
abhandengekommen zwischen dem was
gesundheitspolitisch notwendig ist und
was für wirtschaft und gesellschaft noch
zumutbar ist wir haben seit wochen
sinken der infektionszahlen und ich
finde da hätte man anders drauf
reagieren müssen weil die erwartungen
natürlich in dieser hart betroffenen
wirtschaft also wie in meiner branche
ist natürlich groß gewesen und dann eben
auch gerade mit blick auf andere
branchen die eben hier lockerungen
bekommen konkret genannt werden hat das
hat dann doch für sehr viel unruhe
gesorgt und ja den gipfel haben wir dann
am sonntag erlebt als ministerpräsident
kretschmann also bereits den osterurlaub
abgesagt hat obwohl das noch sieben
wochen hinziehen gesehen dass auch
gleich alles noch ansprechen auch das ja
da eine mutante ob möglicherweise
dazwischen crash zwischen dem
gesundheits und dem wirtschaftsschutz
frau budiman ganz generell zu den corona
hilfen ist es aus ihrer sicht sind eine
junge unternehmerinnen stellvertretende
bundesvorsitzende der
wirtschaftsjunioren hab ich glaube ich
gerade noch vergessen zu sagen bitte mit
diesen kroner hilfen zu viel bestand
erhalten und zu wenig investiert
investiert in zukunftsindustrien in
zukunftsprojekte zu ihrer scheidung muss
ich noch dazu sagen den zuschauern sind
auch gehört dass die teamleitung sehr
schlecht ist wir konnten sie jetzt auch
nicht weiter verbessere
nur als hinweis ergänzt selbst wenn die
hilfsgelder jetzt kommen da gibt es ja
zunächst mal abschlagszahlungen und dann
im nachgang die eigentlichen
unterstützungsleistungen für die
unternehmen da reden wir gleich auch
noch im einzelnen darüber wie die alle
heißen und was die für eine funktion
haben
aber selbst wenn das jetzt kommt wenn
das geld jetzt fließt
haben sie schon ein überblick wie hoch
die insolvenzzahlen in ihrem bereich
seien werden welche unternehmen das
nicht schaffen entweder im prozent oder
in absoluten zahlen haben sie da eine
vermutung
ja das besorgniserregend ist natürlich
dass wir unternehmen sprechen die bisher
vor der krise völlig eigenkapital stark
waren die auch in die zukunft investiert
haben den digital gut aufgestellt haben
waren also auch letztendlich in die
commerce kanal natürlich mit bespielen
und wir haben selber geschätzt dass es
mindestens 50.000 unternehmen sind
möglicherweise jetzt noch mehr je länger
der doch down dauert die diese krise
nicht alleine überstehen können und
insofern war dieser wirtschaftsgipfel
heute zwingend notwendig wir haben als
hdi den schon von über 14 tagen
gefordert und es wäre gut investierte
zeit gewesen wenn heute auch der
bundesfinanzminister
und auch der kanzleramtschef dabei
gewesen wären wenn die kanzlerin selber
nicht die zeit dafür hat dann wäre das
sinnvoll gewesen weil er alt mayer
kämpft wirklich für den wirtschaft wir
haben guten kontakt zu ihnen
aber was uns fehlt grunde genommen eine
gesamtdarstellung dass die gesamte
bundesregierung die interessen der
wirtschaft hier mit aufnimmt und in der
tat vor der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
letzte woche das eigentlich erforderlich
gewesen wäre und die insolvenzen man
ihre frage konkret wir haben eine
aussetzung der insolvenzantrag nicht zur
zeit insofern spüren ihr das gar nicht
wie vermutet ist wir sehen aber dass in
vielen handelsunternehmen das
eigenkapital aufgebraucht ist weil
bisher hier auch gar keine hilfe
angekommen sind auch keine dezember
november hilfen und überbrückungshilfen
im letzten jahr im schnitt pro
unternehmen 10.000 euro ausgemacht haben
bei 200.000 unternehmen die im lockdown
waren und jetzt schon wieder sind seit
über acht wochen
das ist wirklich dramatisch und insofern
muss jetzt schnell gehandelt werden das
hat er altmaier heute zugesagt hat auch
zugesagt dass die großen
handelsunternehmen die bisher völlig
ausgeschlossen war
jetzt auch eine antrags berechtigung
haben aber es muss noch ein bisschen
mehr passieren und in den letzten wochen
haben wir intensive gespräch auch mit
dem finanzministerium geführt und mein
eindruck war dass ihnen die
abstimmungsprozesse zwischen finanz und
wirtschaftsministerium das eigentliche
problem sind warum alles so lange dauert
jetzt haben sie den
bundeswirtschaftsminister etwas in
schutz genommen das hat man aus der
wirtschaft und aus der politik sowieso
in den letzten tagen und wochen auch
schon anders vernommen
manchmal hat man das gefühl dass ich ja
auch peter altmaier die kritik
fokussiert vom politischen gegner
sowieso aber eben auch er sogar aus der
eigenen partei und auch zum beispiel aus
den ländern ist er der alleinschuldige
allein schuldig natürlich nicht
wie schon richtig gesagt worden ist der
finanzminister ist natürlich wenn es um
hilfen um auszahlungen geht ganz
entscheidend das ist seine funktion er
sitzt auf dem geld aber ich vermisse bei
peter altmaier und deswegen glaube ich
schon dass er schuldig ist
auch an der misere dass er sich richtig
einsetzt also eine der größten waffen
des wirtschaftsministers ist eigentlich
die rhetorik er müsste der kanzlerin im
nacken sitzen und sagen so wie der
gesundheitsschutz wichtig ist so ist
auch das überleben der großen teile
unserer wirtschaft wichtig weil sonst
wird das ganze auf längere sicht nicht
funktionieren und wenn ich zum beispiel
sehe wie sich eine frau die für die
kinder stark macht die nervt die
ministerpräsidenten die kanzlerin usw
und sagt die kitas müssen auf die
schulen die grundschulen das geht so
nicht weiter kommt mit dem problem da
passiert was das ist und sie hat auch
nur das wort und der wirtschaftsminister
hat kann sich selbst das geld verteilen
ist oder ob vielleicht den zugang zur
kanzlerin als wird ich glaube nein es
ist das verständnis von herrn altmaier
das war ja vor der bund länder runde
dass er sich als er merkte die kanzlerin
will einen vorsichtigen kurs kein login
dass er sich vor diesem treffen der wird
dieser wichtigen runde
eben schon hinstellt und sagt den
lockerungen können wir uns nicht leisten
genauso wie er heute vor diesem
gipfeltreffen schon sagte na ja die
größte gefahr wäre eine dritte welle
das ist nicht seine aufgabe es gibt ein
gesundheitsminister der muss darauf
achten und er achtet darauf also das
heißt seine rolle nimmt er nicht wahr
sondern er sieht sich als verlängerten
arm der kanzlerin immer zu bremsen und
zu bremsen und das kann dadurch kommt
diese ungleichgewicht also lobbyist in
eigener sache ist aber nicht gerade was
ihm seine bitte könnten sie denn in 60
bis 90 sekunden war die begriffe noch
klären für uns was ist november hilfe
was ist dezember hilfe damit wird in
jeder pressekonferenz in jeder
nachrichtensendung wild schockiert und
dann haben wir noch die
überbrückungshilfen römisch 12 ganz kurz
was muss man sich darunter vorstellen
damit wir wissen was wir darüber gehen
dass er nun gleich noch den im prinzip
sind es immer überbrückungshilfen das
geht ja immer darum diese krise zu
überbrücken das war die erste die wir
beim ersten lockdown in der ersten im
sommer das war sozusagen der große
batzen der ist damals auch wirklich
unbürokratischer ist auch sehr gelobt
worden von der von der wirtschaft weil
damals die länder gleich auszahlten im
nachhinein fest stellten sie zeigen aber
manchmal zu viel und der bund auch jetzt
ja das ist euer problem
deswegen ist und november/dezember hilfe
war die überbrückungshilfe 2 also die
november hilfe diese sehr großzügiger wo
dann plötzlich umgesetzt wurde und man
sagte jetzt gehen wir wir ersetzen
umsatz den umsatz zu ersetzen ist
eigentlich eine völlig irrsinnige größe
weil umsatz sagt nicht unbedingt was
über den gewinn nicht was über die
kosten das ist sehr sehr unterschiedlich
und das merkten die betroffenen dann als
brüssel dann sagte dass könnt ihr nicht
machen dass es teilweise eine
überkompensation das machen wir nicht
mit das ist nicht erlaubt
europarechtlich das war die
überbrückungshilfe zwei deswegen läuft
dir auch so schwierig und da haben die
länder dann gesagt wir gehen nicht
wieder in vorleistung jetzt soll der
bund das mal alleine auszahlen da gab es
nicht mal eine software deswegen diese
verzögerung anfangs abschlagszahlung
also noch immer ist die november hilfe
nicht voll ausgezahlt und dann kam die
dritte die überbrückungshilfe
3 das ist jetzt dann als man sagt also
beim einzelhandel machen wir das anders
weil wenn wir im weihnachtsgeschäft den
umsatz ausgleichen dann wir sind das so
große zahlen
die ist also dann erst kann jetzt erst
beantragt werden und so ist nachnamen
dann gibt es ja auch noch was für
kleinere für solo selbstständige es gibt
jetzt noch ein härtefallfonds also es
ist schon sehr kompliziert aber gut da
ist das heißt dass ein komplexes
instrumentarium das man zur verfügung
hat einmal fixkosten dann weil umsatz
die grundlage jetzt ins wieder die
fixkosten da hatten ja die gastronomen
eigentlich glück gehabt wieder november
hilfe da wurde ja auf umsatzbasis 75
prozent glaube ich ausbezahlt obwohl ja
gar keine umsätze angefallen sind
eigentlich müssten doch die gastronomie
also ihr bereich müsste doch eigentlich
da jetzt ein polster haben um über die
nächste zeit bis zu einer öffnung wir
wissen noch nicht wann hinwegzukommen
also erkenne ich da vielleicht nicht
immer klarstellen wir hatten im frühjahr
die sofort helfen das war die bazooka
die von scholz und als main vorgestellt
wurde und die hat funktioniert
allerdings hat es da auch missbrauch
gegeben
deswegen hatte ich auch schon sehr früh
vorgeschlagen hier die hilfsprogramme
über die finanzverwaltung über die
finanzämter abzuwickeln die können dass
missbrauch sicher gestalten die haben
alle daten vorliegen ist nicht passiert
während andere finanzminister abgelegen
glaube die länder auch nur wir haben das
früher haben dass noch alle abgelehnt so
und dann gab es die überbrückungshilfe 1
die stand allen branchen zur verfügung
die bestimmte umsatzrückgänge hatten und
dann in den voerder monaten
umsatzausfälle hatten und genauso die
überbrückungshilfe 2 die seit september
gegolten hat und dann kam es sie am 28
oktober zu der situation dass man unsere
branche geschlossen hat damit die übrige
wirtschaft geöffnet bleiben kann also
uns wurde ein sonderopfer abverlangt und
dafür haben wir in der tat entschädigung
erwartet und diese entschädigung der
finanziellen ausfälle ist bestandteil
des beschlusses vom 28 oktober die 75
prozent sind so hier von den zuständigen
ministern der bundesregierung genannt
worden die 75 sind aber so zu sehen dass
man geht ja auch das kurzarbeitergeld
noch weg und ich sag mal wenn ich jetzt
anschaue dass wir wir sind jetzt ende
februar dann sechs monate geschlossen
wir waren im frühjahr doppelt so lange
geschlossen wie andere branchen haben da
auch nicht mehr bekommen und wir sind
jetzt seit 2 november geschlossen also
ende februar sind das sechs monate und
ohne perspektive
das heißt sie nur als eine der branchen
wahrscheinlich als letztes geöffnet
werden der einzelnen glauben sie wir
haben auch gute hygiene kontinente und
aber sie stehen doch nicht auf der
agenda der in der politik die jetzt über
öffnungs konzepte redet der ist noch
woher allen branchen daran werden wir
uns ja einbringen und selbst das
robert-koch-institut schafft noch am 27
oktober gesagt dass sony und die
hotellerie kein pandemie treiber ist und
wir haben ja auch gesehen wir waren
schon sechs wochen geschlossen bevor der
handel geschlossen wurde
und es gab ja keine absenken der
infektionszahlen also die schließung
unserer bereiche hat also man
argumentierten immer ja sonst wäre das
wachstum noch größer gewesen und so aber
die betriebe haben wirklich die
restaurants hotels verantwortlich in
schutz und hygiene konzepte investiert
und es ist ja dann auch nur gegründet
worden mit der kontakt reduktion am 28
also wir klappern jetzt erstmal die
branchen die hier vertreten sind in der
sendung einzeln ab um dann die das ist
ja nicht so ein komplexes gebilde mit
dem wir es hier zu tun haben bei den
corona hilfen sondern sicherlich auch
ganz unterschiedlich betroffenen
branchen frau budelmann sie vertreten
hier quasi eine die zukunftsorientierte
industrie was gibt es denn auch da
probleme es gibt ja auch branchen die ja
in der krise richtig profitieren die
richtig brummen ich habe jetzt nicht nur
von den lieferdiensten haben sie da eine
variante anzubieten
dass es in anderen branchen eben anders
aussieht als zb in der gastronomie und
gleich werden was ja auch vom einzel
andy noch hören natürlich gibt es
unternehmen die das allerdings sehr sehr
wenige die sagen dass da
mit beginn des ersten fasses immense
folgen zum beispiel war gut
bestellungen storniert worden sind egal
ob das entwicklung leistung waren oder
prüfungsaufträge und das der grund dass
wirklich darin dass die unternehmen
damals wie heute unglaublich
verunsichert bin alles das was oder
vieles was das für industrielle und ist
bekannt durch starke investitionen und
inhalten die von unsicherheit
gekennzeichnet wird man sich so etwas
nicht leisten und das ist ein großes
problem dass wir auch seit anämie mit
dem bemängeln dass man keine
verlässlichkeit mehr hat und das ist
tatsächlich auch jetzt immer noch das
problem ja wir durften arbeiten aber wir
haben trotzdem weniger sehr sehr viel
weniger kundenaufträge einfach deshalb
weil man sich nicht mehr auf irgendeine
aussage verlassen kann ein mann hat mit
woran man sich entlanghangeln fahnen
unsicherheit ganz ganz problematisch
diese unsicherheit gibt es im
einzelhandel natürlich auch erkennt
jetzt wird ja diskutiert ab wann könnte
es da zu lockerungen des lok downs
kommen da ist ja der einzelhandel ganz
besonders betroffen das heißt es jetzt
wenn die intelligenz die sogenannte
incident 235 pro 100000 einwohner in
sieben tagen bestand hat über mehrere
tage wird davon drei bis fünf vielleicht
auch eine woche dann wird der
einzelhandel auch wieder in diese
lockerung einbezogen haben sie der
hoffnung dass zum beispiel jetzt
nächster größerer fixpunkt im kalender
wäre ostern da dass die meisten
einzelhandelsgeschäfte gerade die
besonders leiden mode lederwaren schuhe
da wieder öffnen können
ja das ist genau der kritikpunkt den wir
haben
zu den hilfen können wir gleich noch was
sagen weil der 23 punkte mir ganz
wichtig sind aber zum thema nach vorne
zu schauen
strategie wir beweisen die momentan im
handel millionenfach jeden tag dass
sicheres einkaufen in dieser pandemie
möglich ist weil so supermärkte
drogeriemärkte discounter haben
natürlich geöffnet tragen dazu bei dass
die versorgung der bevölkerung läuft und
da passieren natürlich millionenfach
kundenkontakte ohne dass es dort zu
besonderen erkrankungen kommt wir haben
gesehen dass die bundesanstalt für
arbeitsmedizin ist untersucht hat
deutlich gesagt dass die mitarbeiterin
im einzelhandel nicht stärker krank sind
aber unterdurchschnittlich um
unterdurchschnittliche zahlen in den
großen supermarkt- und daneben
beispielsweise als im bundesdurchschnitt
und das ist endlich der beweis dafür
dass man mit vernünftigen hygiene
konzepten mit abstandsregeln aber auch
mit dem verhalten jedes einzelnen sicher
durch diese pandemie kommen muss und das
ist unser hauptpunkt wenn wir jetzt über
ostern sprechen das ist überhaupt nicht
die perspektive sondern den beweis nicht
jeden tag dass sie mir auch bei höheren
inzidenz sicheres einkaufen und damit
auch wirtschaften ermöglichen und
deshalb fordern wir natürlich auch eine
öffnung strategie und eine sofortige
respektive in dieser form bis ich finde
es auch nicht gut wenn man branchen
jetzt miteinander vergleicht oder
ausspielen würde das hilft uns auch
nicht weiter
der punkt ist endlich für mich ja nicht
völlig klar dass dieser virus diese
virus pandemie die wird ja das ganze
jahr noch da sein also der virus ist ja
nicht verschwunden selbst wenn wir
bessere durchimpfung rahmen in der
bevölkerung deshalb müssen wir alle
lernen mit diesem virus zu wirtschaften
zu leben und es geht auch nicht um die
abwägung wirtschaft im verhältnis zu
leben denn wir müssen alles tun damit
die erkrankung weniger wir haben die
ansteckung mit stattfinden und weniger
sterbefälle natürlich da sind haben wir
größtes interesse daran
deshalb wir haben das hygiene konzept
für den einzelhandel noch einmal
geschärft mit professor dr exner der
auch zum beraterstab der kanzlerin
gehört und haben das alles vorgelegt und
die hauptkritik die ich jetzt habe das
habe ich vor dem gipfel heute auch
gesagt wir kriegen noch nicht mal
rückkopplungen aus dem kanzler zu diesen
hygiene konzepten die wirtschaft gehört
einfach mit an den tisch nicht weil wir
es besser wissen sondern weil wir glaube
ich einen sehr guten beitrag leisten
können so eindämmung der pandemie wir
sind auch ein wichtiger arbeitgeber der
drei millionen beschäftigte wir können
auch ein weiterer dazu leisten was
kontakt verfolgung anbetrifft in
betrieben kam viel gemacht werden im
rahmen von den genen konzepten und
maßnahmen
wir haben den größten unternehmen haben
mit dem eine beauftragte ihr könnt auch
geld eine erkrankung vorliegt sofort
feststellen mit welchen mitarbeitern war
dann diese person dann im letzten tagen
in kontakt können viel schneller
arbeiten als gesundheitsämter und da
unterstützen
und all das sind punkte die wir
aufnehmen müssen die wir gerne mit
einspielen unsere verantwortung
wahrnehmen aber ganz klar dass beton ist
jetzt auch wieder sukzessive zu öffnen
wir bieten diese sicherheit und wir
können nicht von einem loch darin den
nächsten gehen
übrigens ist es auch keine
differenzierung nach zukunftsunternehmen
und unternehmen die ohnehin keine
zukunftsperspektive haben
der handel war bisher wirklich super
aufgestellt auch der stationäre handel
in den innenstädten viele mode konzepte
beispielsweise auch andere unternehmen
wie natürlich auch zukünftig definitiv
ja sicher wären und die man jetzt durch
diese pandemie begleiten muss und in der
tat wirtschaftshilfen hat der handel
bisher überhaupt noch nicht bekommen
von daher muss man beides miteinander
sehen und die beste hilfe ist in eine
wirklich vernünftige öffnung strategie
nach vorne zu denen die
wirtschaftshilfen komme ich gleich noch
mal so haben sie jetzt auch mehrfach
angesprochen eingefordert also öffnungs
strategien also den lockdown abzumildern
jetzt hat die politik natürlich da ein
problem
das wird zwar immer wieder kritisiert es
gebe zu wenig lockerungen das gelte vor
allem keine öffnung strategie wann wird
wieder geöffnet in welchen stufen
aber die politiker der ein großes
problem sie hat mit diesen mutationen zu
tun die sie nicht einschätzen kann wie
sie sich entwickeln und welchen sinn
macht eine öffnung strategie oder ein
stufenplan wenn nach kurzer zeit eher
wieder verworfen werden muss weil die
fallzahlen wieder steigen im moment sind
sie ja im sinken zwar nicht besonders
stark aber sie sinken kontinuierlich ist
da ist die politik teile auch in einer
zwickmühle
also ich glaube das problem ist dass die
politik
immer noch in der bevölkerung guckt
diese strengen maßnahmen haben immer
noch viel rückhalt und je mehr man hier
über die gefahren möglich die vielleicht
auf deutschland zukommen könnten mit
mutation je mehr darüber geredet wird
umso mehr rückhalt hat sie für ganz
strenge maßnahmen trotzdem wenn man mal
ein bisschen gelassen auf die zahlen
guckt wie sie schon gesagt haben also es
war ja am anfang das ziel eine
überforderung unseres gesundheitssystems
zu verhindern
das ist zurzeit nicht so also es gibt
keine überforderung es gab auch im
winter nirgends eine überforderung es
war immer möglich jeden bestmöglich zu
behandeln und inzwischen wird es immer
tiefer also immer mehr eigentlich
verlangt was gewährleisteten werden muss
bevor man wieder eröffnet und wir haben
regionen mecklenburg vorpommern
beispielsweise da gibt es viele ecken wo
die institute schon die jetzt so geringe
ist also unter 35 und dort will man und
ich halte das genau für den richtigen
ansatz auch sagen da öffnen wir dann
wieder mit den schritten und gerade wenn
man das regionale an solchen in solchen
gegenden tut dann kriegt man ja einen
eindruck davon man muss es mal
ausprobieren was wie entwickelt sich das
wie sieht es dann zwei wochen danach aus
dann hat ist nämlich dieser zeitraum wo
unter umständen ansteckungen entstehen
oder nicht aber wir sind von ländern
üben geben wo die wo der einzelhandel
offen ist und die haben nicht unbedingt
höhere zahlen also polen ist ähnlich wie
wir die haben oft eine öffne läden
italien hat teilweise offene lehnen
frankreich ebenso also es ist nicht so
dass überall da wo der handel geöffnet
hat das dann ein problem da ist und ich
denke ihm gerade in diesen bereichen
lassen sich strenge gegebene maßnahmen
sehr gut durchführen und kontrollieren
und deswegen war das tatsächlich eben
ein bisschen fragwürdig dort eigentlich
einfach zu schließen ohne evidenzbasiert
eigentlich sagen zu können das ist
wirklich ein problem aber es ist
passiert ist das machen ist sowieso das
problem dass man gerade der kroner
vision und schlecht einschätzen kann
dass er das ganz große problem dabei
jetzt fast frau sie uns gesagt man
müsste dann so eine entwicklung sich
angucken nach dem mann
geöffnet hat 14 tage was passiert in
einer branche die so personalintensiv
ist wie die hotel und gaststättenbranche
die ja auch erst wieder hochgefahren
werden musste also eine menge logistik
noch mit dabei wenn sich nach zwei
wochen plötzlich herausstellt die
insolvenzzahlen nicht durch einen
hotspot in den gaststätten sondern wo
anderswo her gehen wieder so durch die
decke dass ich sofort wieder schließen
müssen würde dass ihre branche nicht
auch unglaublich belasten wenn sie damit
rechnen müsste sofort wieder dicht zu
machen also keiner will die dritte welle
und ein rauf und runter fahren das
bringt nichts es ist ja auch ganz
schwierig zu vermitteln wenn man jetzt
sagt in der stadt haben wir ein instanz
wert von unter 35 da wird alles
aufgemacht
was ist denn mit den menschen aus der
umgebung waren die denn alle dorthin
also das ist schon etwas komplexer
gerade auch in touristischen
destinationen wo denn alles gerade ins
schöne mecklenburg vorpommern strömen
würde oder da in die regionen wo der
incidents niedrig ist also das ist schon
mit vielen implikationen verbund ich
würde gerne anderen aspekt ansprechen
und zwar finde ich es ganz ganz wichtig
mich interessiert jetzt auch nicht die
fehlersuche und wer ist schuld etc
sondern wie kriegen wir schnellstmöglich
ausreichend impfstoff hier in
deutschland dass alle menschen die
geimpft werden wollen auch zeitnah die
chance bekommen das hat für mich
priorität 1 2 heute hat sie ersparnis ja
endlich zugesagt dass wir flächendeckend
kostenfrei schnelltests bekommen auch
das ist eine ganz wichtige maßnahme auch
zb für veranstaltungen in unserem
bereich wo man dann entsprechend testen
kann oder auch der hotelier der gastwirt
seine mitarbeiter testen kann
jeden zweiten tag also das ist glaube
ich ganz ganz wichtig und dann muss man
wenn man auf die mutanten verweist aber
hier auch wie in großbritannien mehr
forschen also wir haben ja viel zu spät
ausreichen will ich leben sieht genau
und also die britische variante ist da
heute kann mir die meldung aus haben
und das muss die politik im blick haben
keine frage
und wir haben bis zum dritten märz jetzt
zeit vor allen dingen auch die politik
das zu analysieren
natürlich wollen wir nicht dass erleben
hier was in england in irland in
portugal geschehen ist und das ist eine
hohe verantwortung für die politik aber
sie hat die verantwortung alles zu
unternehmen dass geforscht wird dass die
mittel zur verfügung gestellt werden
impfstoffe schnell test etc
damit es hier auch eine perspektive für
die wirtschaft gibt und nicht einfach zu
sagen das risiko ist da und das können
wir noch nicht einschätzen und und also
es gibt ein infektionsschutzgesetz und
ich kann nicht auf der basis eines nicht
kalkulierbaren risikos rein präventiv
über monate hier alles schließen sondern
erstens dürfen die maßnahmen nur für
vier wochen beschlossen werden
also insofern war es auch verwunderlich
was er gesagt hat mit blick auf ostern
und wir waren zu tun wir haben die
verpflichtung hier jeden tag jede woche
die inzidenz werte anzuschauen
die auslastung der intensivstation und
alle anderen notwendigen faktoren aber
zeitgleich haben wir auch zu schauen was
macht diese situation mit den menschen
mit der gesellschaft also ich nehme da
auch inzwischen andere emotionen war
verzweiflung wächst auch da und es recht
in der betroffenen wirtschaft jahren
einzelhändlern gastronomen hotel.de der
steht mit dem rücken zur wand da werden
ganze lebenswerk chance die da sind und
mir und kalkulierbare wie sind in der
diskussion also dass sie hier auch
stärker auf die wirtschaft auf die
gesellschaften geschaut wird und eines
muss allen klar sein dass es muss das
ziel sein dass kein wirtschaftszweig
länger als einen tag notwendig
geschlossen ist so und da fehlt mir die
energie also sondern sehe da eher in
richtung ja die sorge ist so groß und
hin und her und dass man immer aber nur
auf das schließt dann ist die politik
die politiker offenbar sind aus ihrer
sicht zu vorsichtig denn sie ist ja auch
ein wirtschaftswachstum an wohlstand
interessiert und auch an nicht zu vielen
arbeitslosen unkalkulierbares risiko
erkennt in ihrem bereich wenn du das
noch mal sieht also wir hoffen jetzt
dass die impfstoffe mengenmäßig in
ausreichender zahl kommen dass sie auch
die mutanten wenn sie kommen mit
abmurksen können das also da kein
rückschlag in der impfstoffversorgung
kommt auch die frage von schnelltests
das hat vor hat gerade angesprochen auch
da gibt es ja unsicherheiten in der
handhabung zum beispiel wer macht das
kann man auch selbst machen da gibt es
ja auch sehr häufig auch messe
ungenauigkeiten
wie wird das im einzelhandel den laufen
wenn ist da immer das damoklesschwert
über den 1 händler die dann öffnen und
doch wieder damit rechnen müssen von
einer dritten corona welle weggeschwemmt
zu werden
natürlich ist die große sorge da wir
können uns kann natürlich keine dritte
welle leisten und wir können nicht von
einem loch dauern in den nächsten gehen
dann wäre schade natürlich viel größer
und da bin ich davon was dann
tatsächlich passiert krankenhaus systeme
überlastungen und dergleichen an besser
brauchen wir ein stringentes system mit
verschiedenen bausteinen und ich halte
sehr viel davon das thema impfstrategie
noch mal mit zu nehmen wir haben den
vorschlag gemacht dass die betriebsärzte
die gibt es ja einen größeren
handelsunternehmen nicht im kleinen
mittelständischen unternehmen aber in
größeren handelsunternehmen haben sie
auch betriebsärzte die können übrigens
auch mitfahren wenn der impfstoff
ausreichend da ist ich habe schon gehört
dass ende märz so viel impfstoff kommt
ja gar nicht über die impfzentren
verimpft werden kann
da muss man solche strukturen die
bestehen von betriebsärzten mit hinein
nehmen das wäre ein punkt und die test
strategien ja das ist ganz wesentlich
jetzt nicht im kundenkontakt wir können
natürlich nicht jeden kunden testen der
ein laden betritt aber für die eigenen
mitarbeiter beispielsweise sowohl direkt
neben den kundenkontakt aber auch in den
logistikstrukturen den
lebensmitteleinzelhandel machen wir das
beispielsweise auch schon dass hier
regelmäßige tests durchgeführt werden
damit man ihnen das risiko minimiert
dass man gerade montagmorgens in
fleischverarbeitenden betriebe der einst
man hat ja auch entsprechende fleisch
werde
da laufen solche tests natürlich und
damit kann man vermeiden dass es
entsprechende ansteckungen gibt und dass
alles konsequent auszuführen würde eine
bessere basis bedeuten und zum incidents
wert 5
30 wenn wir uns heute deutschland
anschauen haben wir glaube ich in über
70 kreisen und heute schon über
incidents wert von unter 35 und das auch
schon konstant mehrere tage
die frage ist was folgt jetzt da raus
und der beschluss letzte woche der bund
länder hat er keine klarheit geschaffen
da steht nur dieser zielwert drin und
alles andere bleibt offen hier müssen
die landesregierung jetzt ja die korona
verordnung machen um überhaupt den
einzelnen zu öffnen denn dann steht noch
da drin dass man sich abstimmen muss mit
den nachbarländern nachbarregionen
das alles ist natürlich völlig unklar
hier brauchen wir mehr transparenz mehr
klarheit und insofern kann man das auch
entsprechend umsetzen
wir sind auch im austausch mit anderen
ländern in europa sehr intensiv mit
kollegen in frankreich in italien
beispielsweise und wir haben jetzt ja
einem jahr auch erfahrungen mit diesem
virus zunehmend umzugehen klar die
mutierte variante ist wesentlich
aggressiver
das muss man mit berücksichtigen aber
ich glaube wir haben bewiesen dass man
eben mit diesen konzepten eben auch
immer ein sicheres umfeld schaffen
können und ich liebe das glaube ich auch
jeder in seinem umfeld das die akzeptanz
der bevölkerung immer weniger wird je
weniger transparent nachvollziehbar
solche entscheidungen sind soweit sie
dann auch zufällig getroffen werden und
nicht mehr wirklich evidenzbasiert wie
man so schön sagt sind dass wir brauchen
fakten die man als grundlage hin
und das war vielleicht ein lichtblick
heute in den wirtschaftsgipfel mir dann
altmaier hat uns zugesagt dass ja unsere
ideen vorschläge gesammelt und die dann
auch hoffentlich mit werk wirklich
vorstellen wird im kanzleramt in den
runden auch mit dem ministerpräsidenten
denn das ist an der rolle das war
sicherlich recht seine rolle als
wirtschaftsminister ja natürlich auch
ausfüllen muss daher hat sagte frau sie
vorher aber die ja noch nicht so richtig
ausfüllt aus ihrer sicht das verboten
weil vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz
es ist ja immer die kritik das ist der
tenor ja auch dieser sendung hier dass
der gesundheitsschutz zu lasten eines
schutzes der wirtschaft betont wird
jetzt ist es auch ihre ansicht oder muss
man das vielleicht auch noch anders
austariert wie schmal ist der grat
eigentlich zwischen gesundheitsschutz
und schutz der wirtschaft da hängen
viele arbeitsplätze dran
unglaublich viele umsätze eigentlich
unser ganzer wohlstand eine ziemlich
missliche situation im moment klar dass
man natürlich mit meinen lieben geld
unternehmen aufdecken finde ich der
meinung dass man diese kosten so
vereinfachen kann waren das ist immens
wichtig das haben ja auch bei man das
problem aber noch ordner betont dass man
alle perspektiven mit 1 wir haben ein
sehr gutes gesundheitssystem ich bin
sehr dankbar dafür dass wir hier in
deutschland leben dürfen und die
gesundheitsvorsorge genießt dürfen
allerdings muss uns bewusst sein dass
wir sie auch bezahlen die nicht mit geld
das vom himmel fällt und wir bezahlen
jetzt nicht mit geld das der stadt
irgendwie zur verfügung stellt wenn sie
bis sie mit wirtschaftsleistung und das
ist der springende punkt bei der ganzen
geschichte und wie es ihnen das in
vielen gremien die die politik beraten
und die den entscheidungen zugrunde
liegen
das dortige unternehmen überhaupt nicht
berücksichtigt werden und wenn
berücksichtigt werden
dann wird es sehr häufig eben auch
unternehmen inhalte stimmten us in
ordnung unter bestimmten altersstruktur
dass man tatsächlich junge positionen
berücksichtigt dass man aktiv auf jugend
unter dieses so geht die ihre zukunft
eigentlich noch vor sich gehabt hätten
das ist mir so ist man leider nicht
untergekommen und das ein ganz großes
problem dass hier nach dieser krise wann
auch immer an deren ende dann weise dann
viele kaputte unternehmen geben wird
werden sich alle über wein ist wird auch
viele unternehmen geben wie aufgegeben
werden
das ist uns allen klar nur wer wo sollen
sie doch herkommen irgendjemand muss
sich später wieder generieren und wer
soll's machen ich muss es sein jetzt
leicht meine offenen worte gerade oder
die direkte formulierung wer ist denn
jetzt so blöd und macht noch mal ein
unternehmen auf den nächsten monaten
oder in den nächsten zwei jahren bis
jetzt wo man schwarz auf weiß dass man
alleine gelassen wird und das hilft
werden die nicht schließen
doch man überhaupt keine rechtliche
sichere grundlage für sein
geschäftsmodell hat das ist unser
zentrales problem gar nicht mal
unbedingt ist was tun sondern das was in
den nächsten jahren noch kommt und das
gut sie was ich jetzt ansprechen ist ja
die dass die wirtschaft
sozusagen wieder in gang zu bringen um
das zu verhindern was frau bulmahn jetzt
eindringlich skizziert hat dazu sind ja
diese wirtschaftshilfen da sie haben sie
vorhin referiert sie sich ja zum teil
sehr bürokratisch unübersichtlich wir
reden auch gleich noch über zahlen was
da inzwischen geld geflossen ist
aber ist es nicht auch eine reaktion aus
der erfahrung des frühjahrs dann wenn
ich mich richtig erinnere sie haben
selbst vorhin gesagt einige hilfen sind
da überkompensiert worden
die sondern einfach so zu sagen man hat
mit geld um sich geschmissen sagt ich
jetzt mal so es gab ja auch missbrauch
und betrug dass die politik da
vorsichtig geworden ist weil der
steuerzahler natürlich möchte dass sein
geld auch sinnvoll eingesetzt wird also
immer wenn der staat irgendwelche hilfen
gibt auch wenn er ganz normale soziale
leistung verteilt gibt es auch
missbrauch das ist liegt in der natur
der sache es gibt immer kriminelle
schwarze schafe in dem fall war es auch
teilweise ein bisschen unklar wer
berechtigt ist oder nicht jeder dachte
dann irgendwie auch ich habe auch ein
bisschen schlechter jetzt verdient dann
kann ich da auch mal was beantragen um
eigentlich hinterher festzustellen so
war es nicht gemeint
es ist nur so dass gerade in solchen
bereichen wie gastronomie auch handel
viele sind so an der grenze sie
verdienen und haben auch ein
ordentliches bündnis es läuft aber sie
haben nicht groß was zuzusetzen und dann
ist natürlich relativ schnell dass man
in eine schieflage kommt wenn dann eben
nur drei viertel ersetzt werden drei
viertel ist schon sehr viel für den
staat ist das eine menge was jetzt so
aufgewandt wird
aber es ist eben dann unterhalb der
grenze so kann man dann eben runter
rutschen unter dieses vorher hat sich
das getragen und es wäre auch noch gute
weitergegangen
und selbst jetzt ist es ja so dass wir
natürlich der staat sagt gesetzlich du
darfst gar nicht arbeiten
das dann nach einer entschädigung
einfach zwangsläufig gewährt werden muss
dass die aber natürlich nicht überall
immer passt wenn man jetzt eben verlust
nachweisen muss dass es eben schwierig
ist man braucht fachliche unterstützung
viele können das gar nicht ohne
steuerberater auch der kostet wieder
geld das ist natürlich und dieser
zeitfaktor werden eben plötzlich
lieferanten nicht mehr liefern weil sie
sagen ja
ich glaube ja gar nicht dass das noch
weitergeht oder so dann ist der schaden
auch größer als die in dem man ansetzen
kann
das ist eben genau das problem geht der
staat kann über eine längere zeit nicht
aussetzen was normale nachfrage
eigentlich an wirtschaftskraft bringt
und das versuchen wir jetzt schon
prinzip ein ganzes jahr das ist schon
sehr sehr viel haben vieles ja auch noch
das ganze nächste jahr weil man
unbedingt auch die bundestagswahl
natürlich überstehen will als politiker
aber das wird so im prinzip trotzdem ein
ziemliches blutbad geben also es gab
jetzt vom gak vom deutschen industrie
und handelskammertag die neue umfrage
und wie viele eigentlich fürchten um
ihre existenz gerade in diesen branchen
und das geht eben beim handel und bei
bayer gastronomen da ist es zwischen
einem viertel und einem drittel also und
davon kann man ausgehen dass viele
tatsächlich wissen sie haben
wahrscheinlich keine könnte jetzt der
bazooka von olaf scholz auch die
munition irgendwann mal ausgehen dass in
der enorme beträge die da ausgeschüttet
werden müssen
der bundeswirtschaftsminister hat ja
schon gestern bekannt gegeben hat sie
heute noch mal in der pressekonferenz
gesagt also 90 prozent der
abschlagszahlungen seien ja ausgezahlt
worden und es würden jetzt die noch
ausstehenden zahlungen der
november/dezember hilfen und der
überbrückungshilfe kommen ist das
glauben sie dass das tatsächlich zum
beispiel in ihrer branche demnächst
ankommt mit den abschlagszahlungen kann
man eine zeitlang überbrücken aber man
brauchte die eigentliche hilfe und diese
oft noch nicht ausgezahlt worden also
lassen sie mich zunächst zwei
anmerkungen vorweg schicken erstens das
ganze eu beihilferecht ist mega komplex
und es dauert unendlich lange bis dahin
haben bei der aus genehmigungen für die
entsprechenden
dinge kommen so zweitens da werden immer
ganz große summen in den raum gestellt
ins fenster gestellt sagt man so schön
das waren im frühjahr 50 milliarden für
die soforthilfe über insgesamt an die
betroffene wirtschaft nur 13,8
milliarden abgeflossen sind bei der
überbrückungshilfe im sommer wurden 24,6
milliarden im juni verkündet und da
waren bis ende oktober zwei milliarden
abgerufen und ausgezahlt so und jetzt
sind für den november und dezember geht
es ja auch um die
veranstaltungswirtschaft
kulturwirtschaft die am zweiten november
mit geschlossen wurde
und da sind insgesamt für den november
15 milliarden
dezember 17 milliarden aufgerufen es
sind jetzt anträge für beide monate
gestellt worden stand heute in einem
volumen von 10 milliarden euro und ab
ausgezahlt wurden bislang fünf
milliarden
sodann muss man wissen die
abschlagszahlung betrug zunächst 10.000
euro
das reicht natürlich einen großen
größeren unternehmen was allein 30.000
euro pacht zu zahlen hat nicht aus und
damit klar zu kommen als wir haben eine
aktuelle umfrage durchgeführt am
wochenende da haben sich über 6.000
unternehmen beteiligt und da ist noch
mal deutlich geworden dass 35 prozent
der unternehmen noch keine november
hilfe bekommen haben große unternehmen
die größten arbeitgeber können bei uns
aber gar keine anträge stellen und
dezember hilfe haben lediglich 25
prozent erhalten bis jetzt vollständig
abschlagszahlungen und sind in einem
nennenswerten umfang erfolgt aber die 10
oder respektive 50.000 euro sind
inzwischen helfen natürlich nicht
überall das muss man wissen und wir
gehen jetzt auf den märz zu und die not
ist groß und die krise kennt nicht klein
oder groß sie trifft auch die großen
brutal hart also wenn sie hier
die hotelgruppen in deutschland
anschauen vielfach inhaberfamilien
geführt
sie wissen selber wie es hier in berlin
ausschaut gespenstisch ist ist hier ja
es fehlen die touristen die hotels sind
vielfach zu geschäftsreisende sind nicht
da oder nur ganz wenige also da ist eine
ganz brutale betroffenheit meine frage
war ja auch nach den der zukunft nach
der hoffnung erkennt wenn ich sie vorhin
richtig verstanden habe ist sind sie
jetzt ganz guter dinge dass nach dem
heutigen wirtschaftsgipfel dieses geld
das da immer noch in der pipeline ist
noch nicht ausbezahlt wird vor hat
gesagt ja gerade die zahlen und die
redaktion genannt dass dieses geld jetzt
fließt also man muss das differenziert
sie in der gesamte deutsche einzelhandel
hat im jahr 2020 insgesamt 90 millionen
euro an die unterstützungsleistung
bekommen und dadurch das
kurzarbeitergeld was wirklich die
schnell wirksamste maßnahme waren das
heißt echte unterstützung aus dem
konzertprogramm sind im einzelhandel
nicht angekommen die hand ist als 16
dezember geschlossen hat bis heute kein
geld bekommen das muss man als fakt
nehmen august kassensturz machen
der bundesfinanzminister muss einfach
auch mal sich rechtfertigen wie viel
geld er angekündigt hat und wie viel
ausbezahlt wurde
und das ist genau der punkt dass die
zugangsvoraussetzung immer so hoch
gesetzt wurden
dass viele 1 länder einfach nicht
reingekommen sind die haben sich
natürlich bemüht online umsätze
beispielsweise zu erreichen
die natürlich dann dazu führen dass man
diese dieses umsatzminus wasser als
voraussetzung braucht gar nicht bekommen
und dann gibt es viele details also im
november/dezember hilfe mit bis zu 75
prozent umsatzausfall entschädigung für
die gastronomie ist das eine der handel
ist dann geschlossen worden
dann ist gesagt worden das können wir
aber nicht gleichermaßen machen und das
ist natürlich eine ungleichbehandlung
also es wird auch klagen dem juristische
klagen geben auf zahlung dieser gelder
weil ein unternehmer der einfach auch
verantwortet ist dass ich diesen weg
gehen muss oder nehmen sie das beispiel
überbrückungshilfe der einzelhandel
sollen jetzt rückwirkend ab november
überbrückungshilfe beantragen können er
muss aber mindestens 30 prozent
umsatzminus nachweisen wenn jetzt der
handel am 16 dezember geschlossen wurde
hat er 14 tage umsätze im
weihnachtsgeschäft dann nicht mehr
jetzt nehmen wir nur über den zeitraum
16 dezember bis 16 januar ausgesetzt
werden am 16
können dann kann das dazu führen dass
die unternehmen vier wochen geschlossen
sind und trotzdem kein zehnten
überbrückungshilfe bekommen weil sie
weder im dezember noch im januar
mindestens 30 prozent umsatzminus
gemacht haben wenn man aber im handel 30
prozent oder 20 prozent umsatzminus
macht über eine längere strecke dann ist
man eigentlich pleite weil unser
geschäftsmodell ist natürlich ein völlig
anderes als bei maschinenbau oder
dienstleistungsunternehmen
die umsatzrendite im non food handel der
geschlossen hat liegt ungefähr bei 3
prozent das heißt von 100 euro umsatz
haben sie die umsatzrendite von 3 euro
das ist absolut überschaubar das heißt
das geschäftsmodell funktioniert nicht
mehr
deshalb sind die wirtschaftshilfen nicht
passgenau gesetzt worden und auch wenn
heute der wirtschaftsminister gesagt hat
dass die größeren handelsunternehmen nun
auch über prüfungs hilfe beantragen
können muss es jetzt endlich mal zu
einer auszahlung kommen und es müssen
noch ein paar andere stellgröße
verändert werden
da kämpfen wir lange auch mit anderen
kollegen wie jetzt auch den dehoga
bundesverband ist auch ein
unternehmerlohn beispielsweise bei den
überbrückungshilfe schon gar nicht drin
ist das heißt im handel haben 70 prozent
personengesellschaften dann haftet der
kaufmann darf ich sogar an der stelle
kurz unterbrechen wir gleich verendet
sind ich wollte noch frau budelmann eine
frage stellen muss noch viel mehr geld
in die hand genommen werden
das interessiert ja immer auch junge
unternehmer was schulden angeht
schuldenbremse ist da muss noch mehr
passieren ist es auch eine investition
in die zukunft
rechtlich würden wir sehr gerne einfach
allen voran fangen wir wollen gerne
arbeiten
wir wollen gerne steuern bezahlen
und weil es gerade ja auch um die
zukunft gerichteten fragen gingen was
die überbrückungshilfen angeht dass es
tatsächlich sehr interessant dass man
als unternehmen für die nächsten sechs
monaten exakt umsatzprognose abgeben
muss und was für jeden einzelnen monat
und dann muss ich mir jeden einzelnen
monat auch noch einmal extra kosten
prognose abgeben
jetzt denkt man da ja auch fliegen
kosten die nicht es wird ganz
unterschiedliche kosten wie einen man
ansetzen kann man nicht ansetzen die
regeln ändern sich ständig und wenn ich
jetzt überlege dass das das ist was das
wirtschaftsministerium von ungarn
ihn erwartet dann muss ist als
unternehmer sagen ich hätte gerne mal
eine ähnliche erwartungshaltung an die
politik erfüllt gesehen und das ist
meiner fällt der einfachen und wirklich
helfen um den unternehmen auch vertrauen
und nicht noch weitere dieser fälle ist
sonst eher etwas schwierigen ton leitung
herüberkommen ich bedanke mich bei ihnen
ich bedanke mich bei ihr tag ist aber
dorothea siems bei janine budelmann und
bei stefan genth für die sendung ist ein
bisschen schnell schluss machen morgen
in der phoenix runde liebe zuschauer
ohne bier und blasmusik der politische
aschermittwoch 2021 bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]